there's promising new research when it
comes to sids sudden infant death
syndrome it's a difficult topic for
pediatricians to discuss with families
but one that is very important
hopefully this is it's a just beginning
of you know the end of sits dr kerry
weejay sinha of siena pediatrics is
excited about the latest research as it
pertains to sids sudden infant death
syndrome when a child less than one year
of age passes away in their sleep an
enzyme found in the blood of babies who
passed away from sids was lower compared
to babies who passed from other causes
butyl cholinesterase is the name of the
enzyme and uh really it's it's one of
these enzymes that helps us be able to
work with our nervous system to breathe
to have your heart rate appropriately to
have blood pressure she says this could
possibly be a new marker for
pediatricians time will tell the
researchers are out there trying to
figure out if this is going to be
something that i might have in a
clinical application like my metabolic
screens for example i do on my babies in
the first
week or two of life i can see that
happening or possibly another time she's
seen a lot of research on this topic
over the past two plus decades and is
encouraged by the finding
meantime she tells parents to do the
following what can maybe decrease the
risk of sids
pacifiers and
low
low speed ceiling fans which i think
everybody in vegas right now has their
ceiling fans on on probably high but put
it low speed that's been shown to
actually decrease sids
also make sure to put your baby to sleep
on their backs on a firm mattress do not
have any pillows blankets stuffed
animals or crib bumpers that could
suffocate them